so may I show you the thought process
that was going through my head as I
watched the trailer for we're the
Millers I don't know about this movie I
don't know oh we're the Millers stars
Jason Sudeikis and Jennifer Aniston and
in this film we have Jason Sudeikis who
was a drug dealer very small-time drug
dealer who screws up and loses his stash
so the guy that he answers to is Ed
Helms and he tells him that to make up
for that mistake he's going to have to
go across the border into Mexico and
take this huge amount of weed back into
the states Jason Sudeikis decides that
the best way to be undercover is to look
like a normal American family
so he gets Jennifer Aniston who is a
stripper one of his neighbors who's a
boy whose mom ran out on him and a girl
played by Emma Roberts who's not exactly
homeless but she doesn't exactly have a
place to live either she just crashes on
people's couches all the time he decides
you know what if we act like a regular
American family no one will ever think
that in this RV we are transporting a
whole bunch of weed and so we go on this
big hopefully hilarious adventure with
these people across the entire United
States how was this movie not really
that good unfortunately the movie opens
with something that made my audience
laugh quite a bit a guy is watching all
of these really hilarious YouTube videos
that are famous that's funny because
other people made them and they're funny
but for the movie to open with literally
like three minutes of hilarious YouTube
videos I found that really cheap because
you're using other people's proven
comedy and literally just showing it
during the opening credits to make the
audience laugh a lot I don't find that
clever I just find that kind of
shameless actually I found this film to
be the kind of comedy where everyone in
it is a jerk it's one of those movies
where every single character is
despicable and you're supposed to kind
of enjoy that for some reason as
everyone consistently demeans everyone
and unfortunately if you saw the trailer
for this movie especially the red band
trailer you've literally seen every
single story hit point except for the
last like 10 minutes of the movie as
each scene started I knew exactly what
was going to happen because I saw the
trailer one time and I knew exactly
where each big thing was about to be and
it unfortunately is that way with this
movie they spoiled all the best moments
in the trailer I really like Jason
Sudeikis in Horrible Bosses but here I
didn't really buy his character he seems
nothing like a drug dealer he really
just seems like Jason Sudeikis in this
role and it's gonna make a lot of jokes
it didn't feel like it was grounded in
reality it felt like all the characters
were fully aware they were in a movie
Jennifer Anne
is beautiful she's nice to look at but
she doesn't really do anything special
here either except for one great scene
towards the end of the movie which of
course was also in the trailer I got to
say the best part of this movie is by
far will Poulter he plays the kid in the
movie and he had just this really great
way of just staring at someone and it
was hilarious like he just he was pretty
good in this movie I thought it was by
far the funniest part of course all his
best bits are also in the trailer it's
all spoiled in the trailer and a lot of
guys are going to hate him because he
got paid to do one of the easiest scenes
in film history I'm not gonna spoil it
for you I just didn't find this film
very funny and when a comedy isn't funny
I don't know what else to tell you it's
just not that funny to me some people
will go to this movie and find a lot of
the hugely over-the-top moments funny
and that's fine if you do but for me I'd
like a comedy that makes you think a
little bit that's a little more subtle
there were a couple moments in this
movie that were like that but for the
most part it felt like that a lot of the
jokes were trying to copy off current
pop culture trends to be funny or to be
really outrageous in some way and let's
just show this and it'll be hilarious
because it's disgusting ed Helmes in the
movie I didn't find him funny at all and
for some reason the movie seemed to
think that whales are hilarious because
there are like five whale jokes in this
movie I don't really know why it was
almost like they were just doing it for
fun also the family they meet along the
way has one of the most annoying
characters I've seen all year this wife
I don't remember the actresses name Nick
Offerman is pretty funny though I
enjoyed his character but for the most
part that entire sequence really got on
my nerves because of this wife it was
the most over-the-top like oh we met
another RV family and they're so
annoying like how many times have we
seen that in the movie it's like can we
not do that cliche where you have to run
into this really annoying family I just
found it more annoying than funny and
that's kind of what a lot of where the
millers was for me was more annoying
than funny it has some good moments in
it but for the most part I wouldn't
suggest saying we're the Millers I'm
gonna give it a c-minus
and as always guys thanks very much for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck minh
heist
[Music]